-You guys, we don't always
have enough time
to cover all
the recent news.
So, here with a recap
is one of our writers,
Amber Ruffin, in a segment
we call "Amber Says What?"
♪♪
-[ Speaks indistinctly ]
Things have been crazy.
Okay, first of all,
a rapper named Lil Nas X
released a country song
called "Old Town Road."
And I was like, "What? No one
wants to hear a country song."
Then, I listened to it,
and was like,
"What? This is my new favorite
country song."
And Billboard was like,
"This isn't a country song."
And I was like,
"What would you call this?"
-♪ I take my horse
to the old town road ♪
♪ I'm gonna ride
till I can't no more ♪
-♪ I got the horses
in the back ♪
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah!
Oh, my God!
It is such
a good song!
I wonder why they won't
count it as country.
We....may....never...know.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Then, Billy Ray Cyrus
was like,
"I know how to get it
on the country charts.
I'll do a remix."
And he did.
And Billboard was like, "This
is still not a country song."
And I was like, "Dang.
That [bleep] runs deep."
[ Laughter ]
Also, Gayle King
interviewed R. Kelly.
I was like, "What?"
Then, in the middle
of the interview,
he lost his mind,
and started yelling.
And I was like, "What?"
Check it out.
-[ Indistinct shouting ]
-Robert.
-[ Laughs ]
She was like, "Robert."
[ Laughter ]
And I was like, "What?"
She hit him with
such a good "Robert"
that I sat up straight --
and my name is not even Robert.
Then, I saw the first-ever
picture taken of a black hole.
And I was like, "What?"
Then, I heard the scientist
in charge of getting
that picture was a woman,
and I was like, "What?"
[ Cheers and applause ]
Then, I got so excited I tweeted
a bunch of dirty jokes about it.
And then, my mom saw them,
and I got in trouble.
[ Laughter ]
And that's a true story.
And then, I was like,
"You know what?
Those jokes
weren't that bad."
But then, I looked at them
again, and they kind of were.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, mom!
Then,
Beyonce announced --
[ Speaks indistinctly ]
Then, Beyonce announced that
she'll release a documentary
of her Coachella performance
on April 17th.
And I was like, "What!?"
I got so excited
that I planned a viewing party.
Oh, that reminds me --
Seth?
-Yeah?
-I need the 17th off.
-No. Just watch it at your desk
like everyone else.
-Abuse!
[ Laughter ]
Anyway,
party at my desk.
So, let's see.
What else happened?
Oh. Beto O'Rourke keeps putting
his shoes on countertops
all over the country.
And I'm like,
"What?
Get down from there.
Someone has to
clean that."
Unless he wins
the Democratic nomination.
Then, I'll be like,
"What...a genius."
I love how he puts his shoes
on everything.
Then, I saw Grace Jones,
who is 70 years old,
dance down the runway at the
Tommy Hilfiger fashion show.
And I was like,
"What?"
This woman is
70 years old!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
Now, usually,
when a 70-year-old
dances around with no pants on,
her kids take away her car keys.
[ Laughter ]
Not this supermodel.
Now, how can she look this good
at this age?
I know I say it a lot,
but blackness cannot be cracked.
You cannot crack it.
Freeze it.
Drop it from a building.
Nary a crack shall appear,
for it is the uncrackable.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm 60 years old.
[ Laughter ]
I heard the worst thing
in the world.
Now, this is true.
A woman in Taiwan had four bees
living under her eyelid,
living off of her tears!
I read that article.
I was like, "What?!"
So, just to be safe --
for any bees out there,
my tears are
made of poison.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, dang it!
Oh!
I should have done this.
Go back.
♪ My tears are poison ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
How did I miss that?!
-[ Laughs ]
-Ooh, that was
a close one.
Then, I heard --
-I won the bet!
-Ah!
[ Speaks indistinctly ]
I heard that they dropped the
charges against Jussie Smollett
for wasting everyone's time
by calling in a fake crime.
And I was like, "What?
He's not gonna get in trouble
for reporting
a fake crime?
What is he --
a white woman?"
[ Laughter ]
All these white women
are like, "Yeah."
Then...
Then, in...
[ Laughs ]
Then, in Harry Potter news,
J.K. Rowling was like,
"Dumbledore and Grindelwald had
an intense sexual relationship."
And I was like, "What?
What is wrong with you?
Who asked for this?
And why did you do that?
And when can I read about it
in detail?"
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
I like what I like.
Then, I heard a rhino poacher
got trampled by an elephant
and then eaten by lions
on an animal preserve.
And I was like, "What?
Oh, good idea, animals."
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Work together,
like y'all do in the cartoons.
[Bleep] if those birds
can make Cinderella a dress,
you can stop poaching."
[ Laughter ]
This has been
"Amber Says What?"
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Amber Ruffin, everybody.
There she is.
We'll be right back.
[ Speaks indistinctly ]